ciao a tutti ragazzi e bentornati nel
canale di whale wars
sono molto contento perché sto in
vacanza da da tre settimane i suoi
beckham sia pedara in provincia di
catania che uno dei capoluoghi della
sicilia e mi sto rilassando niente mi
sto rilassando insieme a genitori i
fratelli cugini zii nonni si sta
rilassando per di rete con chiunque
amici in gioiosa e c'è pure un gatto
scroccone con di poter avere a rubarci
il cibo che agli occhi di xmen prima di
portarvi però con me a fare questo
grandissimo atto di coraggio è
necessario portarvi indietro nel tempo
di 5 mesi storico taxi sono le 5 di
mattina e devo partire dominate fra due
ori una volta sull'aereo faccio una
ricchezza velocissima ma il mio buon
senso non mi permette di farvi vedere la
ripresa che ho fatto al mio vicino che
mi stava a fianco stava addormentato e
stava sbavando una puledra in calore non
so quale che problema avesse però un
problema c'era perché se arrivava saliva
era un fiume in piena senza argini c'era
come si tenti fossero stati staccati ha
detto ecco dal momento non posso farvi
vedere questa ripresa perché sarebbe
poco carino nei suoi confronti cercherò
di riprodurre io la ripresa tra 3 2 1
comunque dopo quattro ore di viaggio
compreso scalo ad amsterdam
arriva all'aeroporto di edimburgo ed è
là che mi accorgo che il dialetto locale
pressoché incomprensibile
a questo punto la domanda però sorge più
che spontanea mogliano si possa per che
cosa faceva edimburgo è molto semplice
sono stato invitato in scozia dalla
pixar per andare a vedere l'anteprima di
pregio che in italiano si chiama la
ribelle ebrei ribelle pride qualcosa del
genere ecco per esempio una cosa [ __ ] e
che la protagonista merida a una specie
di criniera di capelli fatta da 1500 più
o meno ciò che individuali di ricci
rossi che svolazzano ovunque e allo
stesso tempo pur non eccellente arciera
e che potrebbe pure far credere che il
film si concretizza in questo
sono la figlia ce le mostra cielo
a
[Musica]
e rinata milano
però no lo giuro il film non finisce
così per una di ripeto una volta finito
il film vengono invitati a un evento di
iniziative legate alla scozia al film
inaspettato porta arrivato cerco di non
fissare troppo i pantaloni neri ma il
ragazzo che mi sta davanti e finco
interesse per uno stand da vicino i
posta bellissime ad accoglierci cose non
bastasse ci stanno dei simpaticissimi
signori in kilt con tanto di suonatori
di cornamusa in kilt anche lui
ovviamente qua da workshop kilt e
cornamusa ha vinto lui a questo punto
dopo un brevissimo benvenuto ci spiegano
che per poter prender parte a delle
competizioni scozzesi bisogna
comportarsi come doveri scozzese 15
piazzano in testa dei cappellini così
dal momento che solo una persona che
cerca ad abbracciare a 360 gradi le
culture e le località che visita credo
che anche per parlare delle attività
scozzesi che abbiamo svolto sia giusto
tornare ad essere un vero un ragazzo
scozzese una volta cambiati ci dividono
in due gruppi e ci mandano fare una
serie di sfide che cercherò di
sintetizzarli più velocemente possibile
cai perciò praticamente lo scopo di
questo gioco è quello di lanciare un
enorme tronco d'albero e farla roteare
in aria cercando di farlo finire il più
diretto possibile quello che ci hanno
spiegato è che non importa alla
lontananza ma perpendicolarità del
tronco durante la mia prova faccio
pagare ma durante la sfida vera e
propria riesco a conquistare un uomo
che insomma schifo non ci fa poi lancia
la sfida dopo quella che mi fa piu
vergognare in assoluto perché quella
nella quale ho fatto veramente schifo
praticamente uno scozzese salterino ha
spiegato individualmente alle due
squadre quali erano i pasti e imparare
per la defezione e siamo le squadre
cerchiamo di fare il possibile per
riparare il ballo ma i risultati insomma
sono sono molto scarsi e la possibilità
di vittoria al quando lontana
ecco perché ho deciso di fare una
dichiarazione che suona tipo perderà la
faccia con quello che sto per fare ma
comunque ci mettono il cuore e dal
metodo non voglio deludere assolutamente
il guglielmo il 5 mesi fa eco montaggio
nel colonnese pezzi più salienti del mio
pallone col messo maggiormente il cuore
si no
beh poi può shop a questo punto dopo
essere riuscito a vincere la sfida del
balletto pensate quanto potevano essere
cani gli avversari capisco che è
arrivato il momento di far prendere di
punta nella mia squadra sfruttando le
mie doti musicali
ecco qui in cui mi esibisco alla grande
con un pezzo di cornamusa visto che
nessuno si fidava darci non intera in
mano come biasimarli of practice
arriviamo all'ultimo sfida il tiro
collasso facciamo tutti quanti un po di
pratica all'inizio tirando un buffo
verso il bersaglio dopo un po abitino ci
annunciano che arrivato il momento della
verità ne sono due vanno lasciati sul
target e ci informano che dobbiamo farle
scoppiare almeno uno con la freccia in
molti provano ma nessuno riesce nel suo
intento
finché non arrivò io per festeggiare la
nostra vittoria la sconfitta dell'altra
squadra ci portano a mangiare che
descrivono un pasticcio separato
rispetto allo stomaco di pecora con
dell'inter llorente animali co ripiegato
cuore polmoni e quali vengono aggiunti
farina d'avena sale spezie la
descrizione semplicemente agghiacciante
raccapricciante ma il sapore del
salsiccione semplicemente fantastico
parola di francesco amadori la sera
vengono invitati a cena insieme alla
stampa e prima di mangiare il signore ci
fa vedere un sacco di rapaci vari
rischiando di farmi asportare le palle
da fusi queste insomma la cena è
meravigliosa ma inquadra solamente il
primo piatto che ci danno perché poi
iniziò a bere e mangiare perdo
totalmente la concezione di reportage
alla fine tornando in albergo mi faccio
una doccia solo solo per indossare i
meravigliosi accappatoio in dotazione e
mary torna in italia tardando laica
questa volta insieme alla camera
giornalista poveri noi
quattro mesi dopo scopro che posso
andare in vacanza che quindi potrò
rilassarmi e parto insieme alla mia
famiglia in macchina in verità l'unica
nota interessante di questo viaggio
le due scazzate di albatros che ci
troviamo sul finestrino per quella dico
siamo pure una moneta da 50 centesimi
per far capire la gravità della
situazione ea quel punto arriviamo a
catania comunque questa esperienza ho
insegnato una cosa che non bisogna
temere nulla e comunque davanti a una
difficoltà bisogna tirare fuori le palle
dopo il concetto dell'onda credo cioè
nel senso se tu hai paura dell'onda
l'onda ti va sopra e chi affoga
se tu non e paure dell'onda con la
tavola da surf a ci fa il surf e ti
diverti pure comunque ragazzi ce la
posso fare
321 grande una seconda volta